it's been over a week since we got our
iphone 13 and 13 pro and after using
both extensively and testing them side
by side i think that everyone's wrong i
found many differences that surprised me
and i have to be honest and say that
unlike last year where i told most
people to just get the iphone 12 this
year it is a much harder choice for four
reasons that i'll be going over in this
video i'll tell you every real world
difference that i noticed both the ways
that the pro is much better and multiple
benefits of buying the non pro 13 and
that's not counting the 200 savings if
you watch through this whole video i'm
confident that you'll have a much easier
time choosing which one of these is best
for you and i'll tell you straight up
which one you should buy let's start
with how these feel in the hand and i
have to say that i prefer the iphone 13.
now sure the pro is made with really
nice stainless steel which is a bit more
protective and i do love the high-end
luxury look of it and the matching
larger camera bump with that shiny
stainless steel around the lenses along
with the back that is matte it just
looks really nice but with that the 13
just feels more comfortable in the hand
the first reason is that even though the
glossy back shows fingerprints more
often especially on colors darker than
my starlight iphone 13 that glass gives
you a much better grip on the phone
instead of the nice feeling but slippery
frosted glass of the pro the second
reason is the weight now sure heavy
phones feel like they are much more
solid but the 13 pro weighs almost 20
percent more than the standard 13 and
it's actually the same weight as the
much larger galaxy note 20 ultra which
has a huge screen and a huge battery now
speaking of batteries the 13 actually
has a larger battery than the pro but
we'll talk about that in just a bit and
neither of these actually come with the
charger so go ahead and pick up our
recommended charger that unlike apples
has folding prongs and it costs less by
using our link down in the video
description this might seem silly but
every time i pick up the iphone 13 it
really stands out to me how noticeable
that weight difference is in the real
world now with that the much larger
camera bump on the pro is much easier to
accidentally touch and get the lenses
dirty and with that if you're somebody
who hates phones wobbling on tables well
the 13 pro wobbles like crazy as far as
the exteriors and the design there's not
many other differences other than having
more color options and just different
colors in general with the 13 and both
have the same excellent ip68
waterproofing rating of 6 meters for 30
minutes which is way better than any
other competition and both of them also
have the same antenna bands and speeds
so you're not really giving up any
performance in terms of download speeds
or reception compared to back in the day
where cheaper phones were a lot worse
and now let's get into probably the
biggest spec sheet difference and that
is the display and the 120 hertz pro
motion technology but before i tell you
if that really matters and i think i
will surprise you first let's cover
brightness and heat both iphone screens
have gotten brighter this year and the
13 pro can reach a thousand nits which
is really nice for some people the 13
now reaches 800 nits up from 625 which
is basically the same as the 12 pro was
last year this screen is basically the
same as last year but without the
artificial software limitation that try
to get you to spend more money now the
13 pro on the other hand has a brand new
ltpo screen which not only gets 28
brighter but it's actually more power
efficient as well so it uses less
battery and it puts out less heat so did
i notice a difference
yeah definitely if you're somebody who
uses their phone in direct sunlight that
1000 nits of brightness is really nice
and if you connect it to say a drone
or you play games outside screen dimming
is less of an issue with the pro but
keep in mind you have to use auto
brightness and it has to be really
bright for the pro to reach that 1000
nits so if you're using manual
brightness or you're indoors they will
look the same now about that dimming
under heavy loads yes the 13 pro can
still dim but when it does it usually
just drops to 80
which is the same as last year's 12 pro
at full brightness compared to all the
way down to 35
which caused me to crash my drone since
i couldn't see the screen once it
suddenly dimmed
with that we found that the 13 pro's
more efficient screen cools down and
recovers really quickly now if you're
somebody that watches a lot of movies or
videos both phones hit the same max 1200
nits for hdr so there's really no
difference there at all and the same
thing goes for speakers unlike last year
where the pro had better bass the
speaker modules seem to be identical and
they are quite a bit louder this year
thanks to a much more improved erp
speaker so i'm really glad to say that
apple has been improving a lot in this
area i also want to let you know to
subscribe if you haven't already since
we are really trying to hit that one
million subscriber mark thank you guys
we really appreciate it and now for that
beautiful smooth pro motion 120 hertz
screen
first off i instantly noticed a
difference when i booted up the 13 pro
and even now one week later i still
notice it every time i use it this is a
feature that i've personally been
waiting for for years from apple and
they have pulled it off even better than
i could have ever hoped for
with some very clever design and coding
but with that said there is one major
downside and no that is not battery life
instead of being stuck at the regular 60
hertz like the iphone 13 it constantly
adjusts from 120 all the way to 10
matching what you're doing or just
trying to save battery life so either if
you're gaming it'll actually make it
smoother than the iphone 13 and overall
there isn't really much of a downside
being able to drop down to 10 hertz
makes a big impact on that battery life
which i'll save for the end of this
video but now i want to tell you my
problem with the iphone 13 pros display
and that is the fact that it is so good
that anything else you use feels slow
and stuttery now not everybody will
notice a huge difference when using this
new screen just like joshua showed off
in his excellent video so if you're used
to a 60hz display you'll be just fine
with iphone 13 but if you try this out
once you get used to it and you go back
and pick up any other device for example
when i would pick up the ipad mini it
was annoyingly choppy to use that and
the same thing goes when i picked up the
iphone 13 after using the pro the screen
on the iphone 13 pro will make you want
to upgrade your ipad if you don't
already own an ipad pro now sure not
everybody's going to care about this but
if you're somebody like me and this bugs
you noticing all the stutteriness after
seeing the amazingly smooth display you
can actually go into the accessibility
settings and limit the frame rate to 60
hertz and on the plus side it still
allows it to be variable down to 10 so
you'll gain even more battery life
benefits actually let's just talk about
that right now like i mentioned the 13
has a bigger battery than the 13 pro but
in the real world you will not notice a
difference in fact the battery life of
the 13 pro is actually slightly better
so even though apple said that the
iphone 13 gains two and a half hours of
battery compared to last year then the
pro gets one and a half hours compared
to the 12 pro you don't actually have to
worry about that and it's interesting
that even on their website they show off
that the 13 pro can stream video for 20
hours compared to just 15 hours with the
iphone 13. and with that let's get into
performance both phones have the same
a15 processor which isn't really that
big of a difference compared to last
year sure it's a little bit more
powerful it's a little bit more
efficient and it's made it to the new
x60 modem which also uses less power but
the biggest difference are the graphics
we have never seen such a difference
between two models like this the regular
f113 has four core graphics which aren't
that much more powerful than last year
probably the smallest upgrade we've had
year over year in a long time but the 13
pro has five core graphics which are a
huge improvement now sure both work for
everything they're gonna throw item
today you're not gonna notice the
difference but the 13 pro has some major
advantages it actually doesn't use any
more power than iphone 12 pros from last
year but it gets much better performance
and then on the flip side if you're not
pushing the graphics very much
it is actually more efficient than the
four core model because it doesn't have
to clock up as high to do that work so
that also saves you battery life with
that you can actually enable battery
saving mode and that will basically give
you the same performance as the 13 but
using less power and less heat at the
same time now of course that doesn't
really matter for a lot of people but i
would just say keep this in mind that
you're not buying this phone for a year
a lot of people now are upgrading every
three years maybe every four years so if
you spend the extra money now that extra
graphics performance is gonna mean that
you could still play games and run
high-end apps for maybe a year or maybe
two years longer than you could with the
regular 13. with that the 13 pro also
has 6 gigs of ram compared to 4 gigs and
yes it is noticeable in the real world
especially if you're somebody that
multitasks like i do with some tougher
apps like games or apps upload a lot of
data like social media apps and there's
really nothing more annoying than
loading up youtube so you're watching a
video then you go to the camera app
which uses a lot of ram take a photo and
you go back and your youtube video the
whole app is closed you got to go find
it again or say if you're posting or
reading something on a app like social
media and it is now gone so that is
definitely money well spent to have that
and of course that also helps with
future proofing and now let's talk about
the cameras because we have a lot of
differences here the iphone 13 inherited
the main camera from the very best
iphone last year the 12 pro max and the
ultra has been improved too but the 13
pro has an even bigger improvement this
year with huge upgrades on both those
lenses along with a brand new three
times telephoto camera which gives you
much better zoom shots than the 13 which
lacks this for low light shots the pro's
ultra lens lets in much more light and
it can take nighttime portraits due to
the lighter sensor with that the 13 pro
has a macro mode which can get crazy
close to the subject thanks to the new
ultra lens being able to focus which the
13 can't you also get support for prores
video and apple raw photos which i
almost never use anyway but in general
the difference in cameras this year is
much much bigger than last year i'm
actually working on a very detailed
comparison between these two showing off
every different situation and how the
images compare so if you guys want to
see for yourself what the differences
are for the type of shots that you shoot
i would say make sure you guys have
those notifications enabled so you guys
don't miss out on that video i'll just
say that if you care about camera
quality and capabilities with different
features the 13 pro is definitely for
you and with that with all of these
differences that i mentioned this year
unlike last year the 13 pro is well
worth the extra 200
if you are buying a new iphone this year
make sure it is the iphone 13 pro you
will not regret it or maybe the 13 pro
max which we just did a super detailed
review on which you guys could check out
right over there go ahead and click that
subscribe button above if you guys want
to help us reach our goal of 1 million
subscribers this has been max and i will
see you in the next video
[Music]